natürlich in regalen oder die liebe
kann man eher der essen künstlerin und
köchin lauren wildbolz pfeift auf solche
bedenken seit sie vegan lebt
experimentiert sie mit völlig neuen
lebensmitteln die ehre vom komposthaufen
will sie zu keksen verarbeiten die idee
lieferte medienberichte nach dem
erdbeben wildbolz hat vegane ernährung
zu ihrer mission gemacht will genau
wissen woher kommt was sie ist gemüse
und kräuter kauft sie vom örtlichen
bauern und vegan galt bis vor kurzem
noch als schrullig inzwischen ist es ein
trend in den städten die künstlerin die
seit ihrer teenagerzeit auf fleisch
verzichtet stellt er vor acht jahren auf
vegan und merkte schnell dass bedeutet
mehr als nur anders essen
kritiker behaupten veganer sein genuss
feindlich und moralisierend zu
ideologisch fast schon religiös die
meisten veganer aber wollen missständen
etwas entgegensetzen
rund um die ernährungsindustrie wie sie
auch im aktuellen film zehn milliarden
thematisiert werden
es geht um den umgang mit tieren
männliche küken zum beispiel für die
eierproduktion wertlos werden in
fleischfabriken getötet und geschreddert
es geht um ressourcenverschwendung ein
drittel der weltgetreideernte wird an
tiere verfüttert
davon könnten vier milliarden menschen
mehr satt werden
und es geht um umweltbelastung
klimawandel der co2 ausstoß durch die
produktion von rindfleisch ist gewaltig
ein kilo rindfleisch verursacht ähnlich
viel co2 wie eine lange autofahrt in den
süden
andererseits gehören fleisch eier und
milchprodukte nicht zu unserer
gewachsenen kultur möglich doch viel
scheint die vegane lebensweise utopisch
und aufwendig produkte müssen
ausgetauscht werden
manche behaupten sogar veganer müssen
ihren freundeskreis auswechseln für
lauren wildbolz ist vegan ein
politisches statement dass sie mit
großer lust verbreitet keine
einschränkung sondern eine genuss
betonte erweiterung des speiseplans
einen anstoß zum nachdenken über das was
wir drei mal pro tag zu uns nehmen so
wie sie es in ihren kochkursen
vermitteln wie hier bei der zubereitung
eines 10 gang menüs nicht einer der
teilnehmer hier ist übrigens veganer
ich würde gerne vegetarier sein
vielleicht kommt noch bis zumindest
mailand stoß vegan essen kann gutschmidt
zwar muss man auf mangelerscheinungen
achtgeben wildbolz sieht darin aber kein
problem
darf man schleich in ihrer gegenwart nur
noch heimlich essen wie streng muss man
sein als veganer kulinarik spitze
bringen
auch mit ihrem kunstprojekt drechsel
geht es wild ball zum alternativen zu
unserem traditionellen speiseplan hunger
durch erde stillen in drittweltländern
of pure notwendigkeit in der schweiz
aber nur mit genehmigung möglich
zeit für die erste geschmacksprobe
wildbolz will beweisen nahrung aus erde
die sie hier zusammen mit einem bio
bäcker entwickelt kann eine option sein
es geht eigentlich um das erlebnis der
asse und ich die leute bringen und in
dem moment vor dem kuss oder vor dem
moment horizonte widrig pflicht
stattfinde gedankengang freisetze wo ich
jetzt nicht wirklich stören bot aber als
ich sehr
lauren wildbolz will mit ihren es
konzepten stören aufrütteln zeigen dass
wir eine wahl haben ob die wege an heißt
vegetarisch
oder einfach bewusster essen das
entscheidet immer noch jeder für sich